[Music]
let's go to uh in in
sacramento what's up ann
hello thank you for taking my call you
got it what's up um i have
two adult
sons
they both
have girlfriends that they've had for
long terms
both of the sons are moved out of the
home
the girlfriends do not care for each
other
[Laughter]
fix it mom
fix it and i don't want to be the
interfering person
i've always tried to not not to be
i don't know what to do because now it
has
not only
it now it's filtered into the
relationship with the brothers
um when it hadn't really
um
but that's it's now come to us
absolutely at some point
a good girlfriend
will say you choose family or me
right and i'm being facetious about good
girlfriend
um
i'm being sarcastic of course no nobody
should ever do that it's obnoxious and
it's silly and and this is where you are
so here's here's the quick answer what
can you do
literally nothing
like pragmatically nothing
here's what i would do if i was you
though okay
okay so
basically you just called and said all
right
it's fourth and twenty
we're down by eight points how do i win
this game and i just said there's pretty
much no way you can win but here's what
i would try anyway okay here's your hail
mary pass
i would
either get in person
that's the best
or get on a three-way call
or
write a letter
the exact same letter to both boys
and say
enough is enough is enough
as your mother i'm not willing to see
our family implode over two girlfriends
who can't get along
and yes that's very dismissive these pro
guys probably see them as more than
their girlfriends they probably see them
as their futures and their this is and
all the things
but the only appeal you have is to get
the brothers back in a room
are you really willing to lose your
brothership your brotherhoodness i don't
know the right word there
um
are you really
willing to cash out our family
connection over this spat between these
two girlfriends
and
prepare your heart
annie because they may pick the girl
they may pick the girl but here's the
weird thing it's your picture that blew
up not theirs
right
you had this picture of the boys are
gonna meet these beautiful girls we're
gonna have these hilarious times and me
and the girls are gonna go out we're
gonna do these fun things and we're
gonna hassle the boy and that's not
happening
because for whatever reason these two
girlfriends are acting like idiots
and then your sons decided hey acting
like an idiot looks like fun we'll be
idiots too and then they joined in
i'm so sorry that your picture is just
in tatters
unfortunately i know it is um because
they were very very close yeah
um until
what happened was there a big thing was
there a big blow up or dust up or
something
um
this has been gone on for
several years
and i think this the personalities
between the girls are very different
they don't mesh i don't know if there's
jealousy
involved
and um oh the two brothers love each
other
oh yes they do and um
it finally came to a head i mean i we've
kind of started to notice that and this
is what i think this lead with like the
come to a head part this is the good
gossipy part lead with this what
happened
um
that's jerry springer this thing what
happened
one of the brothers decided you know
what enough is enough
let's talk
um so we can clear this up
and
instead of it getting resolved
and you know okay the girls need to talk
you know they need to get together they
need to talk because this was their
issue you know between the two of them
and
um
so the girls end up talking
i don't really know
how that went like i don't think it went
horrible but it didn't completely it
didn't resolve it
um should have checked out the hook or
the dj
things that needed to be said were said
um and then they said well
but i think then they went back to their
respective you know boyfriend and
um then the boyfriend kind of became
defensive about
the things that were said about the
other person
and
you know the one brother kind of said
okay i just need to take i need to take
a break from this we need there's got to
be a break from this
and then we'll figure out how to move
forward
so there's no big like like
then susie slept with dan and they're
not like there's none of that oh gosh no
no no no no no no okay so it's it's like
i don't like your hair well she's
annoying she laughs too loud she doesn't
even call my birthday she even followed
me on facebook and that led to a
i'm not going to talk to you at a party
which i can't believe she didn't i'm not
talking to her then
and then all of a sudden you wake up and
it's two years and now no one will be in
the same room together
right exactly yes exactly
this is the worst
it's the worst
i hate it i'm smiling out of just
sadness i i hate it for you
i hate it for you because it's not
supposed to be that way people supposed
to be adults and grown up no
no exactly and maybe those girlfriends
are never gonna be best like
bro down friends that's fine but they
can be cordial and laugh they can at
least lie and pretend when the family
gets together
right you know that was that's all my my
expectation is and i thought if i
eventually needed to approach it
would approach it just never going to be
a best friend
but we have to accept each other and be
cordial at least minimally and i will
also say this it could definitely evolve
into something better it kind of goes on
that's a fantasy
and
i also preach boundaries like crazy here
and if you keep going to if if a young
couple gets married and they keep going
to thanksgiving and mom's bananas and
dads always
ranting about politics and
brother and sister don't
like at some point i tell people stop
going
stop going choose to be whole and yes
it's gonna hurt and yes it's gonna
ricochet through everyone else's family
issues but stop going just stop
and at some level that may have happened
the only shot you've got is to reach out
to the boys i i guess you could reach
out to the girls
um you could
and just say it's hurting me
i mean you could play that card if you
want but i definitely wouldn't do that
um
i'd reach out to the boys and just say
guys i just
i'm losing my family here and i don't
like it
kelly's shaking her head no why not
don't
sorry we agree don't reach out to the
girls oh i just said that's a terrible
idea yeah reach just out to the boys
okay okay so forget what kelly just said
for sure when you get off this phone
call the girls both of them and say
listen here ladies i'm editing this out
don't do that and yeah i'll call the
boys and say i'm losing my family i
don't like it
[Music]
i raised you all better than this i
raise you to be mature raise you to love
each other i raise you to have each
other's backs
i also raise you to be grown-ups when
people say mean things about your
girlfriend you're not in middle school
anymore i'm not going back out sky i'll
meet me at the hills at three o'clock
what a con what are we doing
we're grown-ups
and just be prepared for them to pick
the girl too
it's both and
but at least you'll be able to sleep at
night knowing i have spoken my peace my
sons made their grown-up decisions
honestly just like i raised them to
and
now you get to grieve the holidays that
aren't going to happen and then you and
your husband get to decide what happens
next and that's hard and that's annoying
and that's not what anybody wants and
that's reality
grief is the gap between what we wanted
and what we hope for
and what actually happens it's just that
space
and you're having to sit in that space
and it's uncomfortable and it's not fun
but it's your space to sit in
i'm sorry
reach out to them and let me know be
bold with them be bold
let them know how you really feel don't
hedge your bets say the words that you
want to say
be reckless in your love for them and
for your family
and then let me know how that
conversation goes